buonasera a tutti quando si parla di
bilinguismo
normalmente la sua socia un tema
impegnativo sul piano sociale politico
cioè quello dell'identità etnica
pur senza legale l'importanza di questo
tipo di approccio
se ne può proporre uno alternativo che
fa leva invece sui vantaggi cognitivi
del bilinguismo
in particolare del bilinguismo precoce
per capire in che senso si parla di
questi vantaggi possiamo riferirci a un
problema quello dello sviluppo delle
lingue e della loro capacità di
trasformarsi assorbendo anche
significati nuovi come avviene questo
processo
partiamo da un esempio poniamo di avere
una lingua iconica cioè una lingua che
come i geroglifici egiziani faccia
riferimento alle capacità
rappresentative e istituisca quindi un
legame di tipo figurativo tra il segno
di geroni fico è ciò che il segno denota
ciò qui si riferisce e poniamo che
all'improvviso per caso o per maggiore
efficienza un parlante introduca in
questo sistema un segno convenzionale
arbitrario che non c'entra niente con
l'oggetto denotato come appunto la
nostra parola a casa che non ha nessun
legame di somiglianza con l'oggetto di
riferimento come fanno i parlanti a
capire questo nuovo segno totalmente
estraneo rispetto alla struttura della
lingua è evidente che questa capacità di
comprensione è legata alla a un processo
che eviti ogni forma di interruzione
della comunicazione se cioè il segno
estraneo può essere compreso in virtù
del suo rapporto con gli altri presenti
nel contesto allora chiaramente per chi
sente questo nuovo segno non ci sarà
nessuna difficoltà a comprenderlo
quindi abbiamo un duplice meccanismo il
radicamento cioè il fatto che il nuovo
segno in qualche modo si radichi si
ponga in connessione stretta con gli
altri presenti nel linguaggio è
ugualmente utili
i dati e la capacità di innovazione
la proiezione in un altrove in qualcosa
di totalmente nuovo
ecco questo processo dà origine a un
meccanismo che possiamo chiamare di
flessibilità contestualmente vincolata
per cui da una parte c'è il radicamento
cioè il vincolo e dall'altra parte
invece c'è la capacità di proiezione
nell'altrove nell'altrimenti che genera
appunto innovazione per spiegare questo
meccanismo si avanza oggi l'ipotesi che
nel nell'apparato cognitivo umano esista
un sistema che viene chiamato sistema
triadico di radicamento e proiezione che
spiega appunto questa duplice capacità
di radicamento per un verso e di
proiezione per l'altro di questo
dispositivo di questo meccanismo fanno
parte tre tipi di intelligenza
l'intelligenza ecologica che è
sostanzialmente legata a dispositivi di
rappresentazione dello spazio ea
capacità di far interagire il sistema
percettivo e quello dell'azione
l'intelligenza sociale che è legata alla
capacità di rappresentarsi ciò che pensa
o vede un altro la capacità di entrare
nella pelle di un altro attraverso la
quale si riesce a costruire uno sfondo
condiviso a livello sociale e infine la
intelligenza temporale legata alla
capacità di viaggiare nel tempo sia
riandando con la memoria al passato sia
anticipando con le previsioni e con le
ipotesi il futuro questi tre sistemi di
elaborazione dell'informazione pur
essendo tra loro estremamente diversi
sono comunque accomunati da un aspetto e
cioè dal fatto che tutte e tre funziona
in appunto sulla base di un meccanismo
che per un verso radica ancora
all'ambiente e per l'altro verso
proietta in uno spazio alternativo
di questo tipo di meccanismo si servì in
qualche modo e adesso fece molte volte
riferimento giacomo leopardi che nel suo
zibaldone parla a questo proposito di
visione doppia l'espressione con cui
leopardi parla di questa visione è
talmente precisa e bella che non mi
azzardo neanche a riassumerle per questo
la voglio leggere direttamente all uomo
sensibile immaginoso che viva come io
sono vissuto gran tempo
sentendo di continuo e immaginando il
mondo e gli oggetti sono in un certo
modo doppi e li vedrà con gli occhi una
torre una campagna udrà con gli orecchi
un suono di una campana e nel tempo
stesso con l'immaginazione vedrà
un'altra torre un'altra campagna umbra
un altro suono in questo secondo genere
gli obietti sta tutto il bello e il
piacevole delle cose trista quella vita
ed è portare la vita comunemente che non
vede non ode non sente
senonché oggetti semplici quelli soli di
quegli occhi gli orecchi che gli altri
sentimenti ricevono la sensazione e
quindi leopardi ci parla di un immagine
seconda e di una strategia dello sguardo
che in qualche modo riesce ad alimentare
ad arricchire ciò che vediamo con le
capacità della fantasia e
dell'immaginazione in questo modo non si
appiattisce sulla realtà come ma disegna
una realtà che è fatta allo stesso tempo
di percezione e di immaginazione e
quindi ancora una volta di senso della
realtà e di radicamento e di senso della
possibilità cioè capacità di proiezione
nell'altrove che cosa c'entra questo con
il bilinguismo c'entra evidentemente
perché un bambino che genera precoce
venga in qualche modo abituato a
utilizzare correntemente la quella che
possiamo chiamare la lingua del luogo la
lingua cioè che esprime al meglio la
storia
i tratti distintivi dell'ambiente
sociale in cui vive
chiaramente acquisterà una maggiore
capacità di radicamento in questo
ambiente
dall'altra parte la conoscenza di una
seconda lingua meno legata non legati in
maniera più indiretta all'ambiente di
riferimento lo doterà di quella capacità
già in età precoce di proiezione
nell'altrove soprattutto lo noterà della
capacità di scegliere tra un doppio
registro linguistico e quindi di
separare la parola e il significato
proprio perché dispone della possibilità
di esprimere lo stesso significato con
più parole appartenenti a linguaggi
diversi
c'è un altro aspetto che va sottolineato
per evidenziare i vantaggi del
bilinguismo e quello che legato ai
processi della comunicazione
la comunicazione è stata in un primo
momento modellizzata da jacobson il
quale forniva un modello abbastanza
semplificato nell'ambito del quale il
baricentro era tutto concentrato sul
messaggio e sul fatto che questo
messaggio dovesse passare in qualche
maniera inalterato dal mittente al
destinatario si postulava dunque che
mittente destinatario dovessero agire
all'interno dello stesso contesto
possedere ovviamente lo stesso codice
tenendo presente anche il canale diretto
via telefono via televisione attraverso
il quale il codice viene erogato e
utilizzato il presupposto da questo
punto di vista era che non ci fossero
frizioni ostacoli al passaggio
inalterato del messaggio da dal mittente
al destinatario che questa sia un
processo estremamente semplificato al
limite della banalizzazione lo hanno
messo in evidenza due studiosi russi un
semiologo lotman è uno dei più grandi
matematici del novecento e cioè colmo
goro che hanno messo in evidenza come
in realtà ogni processo di comunicazione
anche il più semplice sia un processo di
traduzione dalla lingua dell'io alla
lingua del tu e anche se questi due
parlanti parlano la medesima lingua
chiaramente i codici che utilizzano i
sottocodici di questa lingua che
utilizzano sono non necessariamente
identici questo lo si vede molto bene
quando in italiano ascoltiamo ad esempio
la conferenza di uno specialista in una
disciplina che non mi appartiene e di
cui quindi faccio fatica a seguire i
significati ai contenuti e bene in
questo caso il problema di fondo che
viene evidenziato è questo che siccome i
codici sono diversi e la parte che del
messaggio che il destinatario recepisce
posto che appunto i codici non
coincidono totalmente è quella più
interessante cioè quella che
caratterizza con nota i tratti
distintivi del mittente rispetto al
destinatario medesimo cioè la parte del
messaggio che va persa proprio quella
più originale quello che il destinatario
non sa è che il mittente cerca in
qualche modo di comunicare come si fa a
porre rimedio a questa carenza nei
processi comunicativi prendendo atto del
fatto dice lotman che anche il processo
comunicativo più semplice e più banale
diciamo presuppone alla presenza non di
due soggetti ma almeno quattro e cioè il
mittente e il destinatario il modello
del destinatario che il mittente si deve
fare per poter indirizzare un messaggio
mirato cioè che il destinatario sia in
grado di capire e il modello del
mittente che il destinatario si deve
fare per rispondergli in maniera
adeguata
e allora da questo punto di vista è
evidente che lo sforzo fondamentale deve
essere quello di diventare buoni
traduttori in modo da entrare in qualche
modo
nella testa dell'altro e di indirizzarli
un messaggio che sia alla sua portata
allora da questo punto di vista il
vantaggio di un di lingue evidente
essendo abituato a scegliere tra due
registri linguistici differenti in base
alla loro maggiore efficacia rispetto a
una determinata situazione comunicativa
in cui si trova il bilingue e anche più
capace di fare questa operazione di
entrare nella testa dell'altro del
destinatario e di calibrare un messaggio
su misura adatto per la sua comprensione
e quindi da questo punto di vista il
bilingue si trova in una condizione
migliore sotto il profilo dell'efficacia
dei processi comunicativi
c'è infine un terzo vantaggio che è
interessante e importante che oggi viene
messo in rilievo in particolare dagli
psicologi cioè quando diciamo qualcuno
dispone di due registri linguistici
è evidente che nel cervello questi due o
più registri linguistici sono attivi
contemporaneamente ma l'uno non deve
disturbare lo sviluppo dell'altro per
cui sostanzialmente quando io utilizzo
uno dei due
devo essere in condizione di disattivare
in tutto o in parte meglio in tutto che
in parte
l'altro il registro linguistico in modo
che non interferisca con quello che sto
utilizzando in questo momento
questa si chiama capacità di inibizione
cioè la capacità di inibire
momentaneamente di bloccare
momentaneamente l'efficacia di processi
linguistici o cognitivi di cui pur si
dispone perché questo aspetto è
interessante perché noi sappiamo che
soprattutto in età adolescenziale
c'è un doppio problema che l'adolescente
appunto deve affrontare da una parte la
sua capacità di aggregazione
possiamo chiamarla diffusionali ta cioè
di amalgamarsi al gruppo degli amici dei
compagni acquisendo quindi capacità
anche sofisticate di relazione sociale
dall'altra parte però evitare che
all'interno di questo processo di
aggregazione e il soggetto si comporti
come una pecora che segue segue
pedissequamente i comportamenti degli
altri che magari per essere accettato
dal gruppo sostanzialmente né ricalchi i
comportamenti la decisione e le scelte
il tutto a prezzo chiaramente un
processo maturo di individuazione e
allora sotto questo profilo la capacità
di inibizione e fondamentale perché se
la si acquisisce l'adolescente riesce si
sa inserirsi nel gruppo a emularne i
comportamenti quando ritiene che questi
comportamenti siano degni di essere
riprodotti ma è anche in condizione di
dire di no
rispetto a decisioni e scelte o
comportamenti che non lo convincano
bloccando quindi con un processo inibiti
vo il passaggio dalla visione di ciò che
gli altri fanno alla propria azione e
sostanzialmente quindi rimanendo
all'interno di una sfera di capacità
autonoma di decisione e di elaborazione
quindi abbiamo visto il di lingue
precoce è in condizione di acquisire
meglio la capacità di radicarsi
nell'ambiente ma anche di immaginare
contesti altri quindi di vedere e
pensare altrimenti riesce meglio a
calarsi nei panni del destinatario
quando deve attivare un processo
comunicativo e a scegliere la forma di
linguaggio e di espressione più efficace
ai fini della riuscita della
comunicazione
e infine è in grado di relazionarsi con
gli altri senza per questo
necessariamente riprodurle
pedissequamente i comportamenti e quindi
diciamo unendo la capacità di relazione
sociale con la capacità di sviluppare
autonomamente le proprie scelte e
decisioni sono tre vantaggi con i tipi
fondamentali per lo sviluppo e per la
crescita
e se come sembra e come abbiamo cercato
di dire il bilinguismo aiuta a
sviluppare questi tre meccanismi il suo
vantaggio cognitivo
al di là di ogni posizione etnocentrica
risulta evidente